- It's a work that is very much about
entering into an immersive environment.
We try to make each
installation very unique
to the actual space it's installed.
In the mountain atrium, it's that
you're able to work with the verticallity
for the first time of the work.
Using nine screens where you're able
to sort of move between screens,
or view them from different angles.
We'll try to encapsulate
this idea of movement
within the work, but also
how you view the work.
What inspiration for Ten Thousand Waves
begins in more conveying.
In 2004, when 23 chinese
cocal shell pickers
from the Fujian province from China
died when they were trying
to pick for cocal shells
in the north of England, I felt very
moved by the tragedy because they had come
from such a far distance to meet
this kind of horrid end, and I thought
it would be very interesting to try to
view this tragedy not from the current
European point of view,
but (mumbling) from a
Chinese point of view.
And it took us about three years
to discover the Mazu fables.
Mazu is the sea goddess
from the Fujian province
where the Chinese cocal shell
pickers originated from.
And one of the things that I thought
that would be very interesting,
so try to view this
from Mazu's point of view, and in bringing
the lost souls back to China, so to speak,
through Mazu's journey, which spans over,
I would say, 400 years of Chinese history,
begins in modern day, then
we go to 30s Shanghai,
and then we end up in the Ming period
in 15th century China.
We shot in the Guangji province in China.
Of course, having Maggie Cheung play Mazu
was sort of very important,
and one of the things,
I think, in relationship
to making it work,
was the idea of trying to
use (mumbling) devices,
ways of trying to alert the audience
that they're watching a film.
For example, in the green screen section,
when you foreground it, it
doesn't necessarily take away
let's say, the magic of those scenes,
in the same way that there's labor into
people picking cocal shells
or there's labor into making images,
and you can't make images
without that labor.
One of the important collaborations
was working with different composers.
Jah Wobble has a band called
the Chinese Dub Orchestra,
so that's this marriage between
east and west in his work.
And then, of course, there's
the work that was done
by the sound designer, Mukul
Patel, and also Adam Finch
who is the multiple screen
editor for my works.
And then the 9.2 surround sound dubbing
that we made for the work was very unique.
We're trying to make a
piece of work that would
have sound become more
sculptural in the space,
also become foregrounded
as well as the image.
And, in a way, when you
make a multiple screen work,
you're able to make
those kind of decisions
in a much more, sort of, creative manner.
There are all of these
sort of aesthetic quests
that we wanted to sort of
pursue and make in the work
to make it a unique experience.